[Musique]
stone
la vie de député appliquent parfois de
se déplacer dans des lieux peu
hospitalier la député de
westmount-saint-louis est accompagné de
david chapman le directeur d'un refuge
pour itinérants et ce matin c'est cesser
de rejoindre les personnes qui sont les
plus vulnérables pour moi de rencontrer
les personnes itinérantes c'est
tellement important parce que ça reste
que ce sont des êtres humains et les
refuges ont la difficulté avec les
pandémies maintenant il peut plus
accueillir du monde fait qu'on a de plus
en plus du monde qui sont à l'extérieur
qui n'ont pas d'abri qui vit dans les
tentes
[Musique]
voulu donner plus mais pour être en
mesure de donner plusieurs cartes
cadeaux c'est la façon de le parti c'est
un repas pour deux personnes
peut-être
ce qui m'a emmené à la politique c'est
mes enfants moi j'ai deux enfants
extraordinaires qui vit avec le spectre
de l'autisme
alors c'est une cause qui est très
personnel pour moi ce jour là samuel 19
ans étudiant au cégep accompagné sa mère
députés il a choisi de faire d'elle sur
ce sujet principal pour un travail
scolaire être un enfant handicapé ou
autistes puis faire l'école à distance à
temps plein c'est vraiment pas une
formule de succès c'est pas gagnant le
santé mentale de monfils souffre
beaucoup j'ai même dû prendre une
semaine de congé de l'assemblée pour
passer du temps avec lui parce que les
pensées noires c'est pas facile
[Musique]
comme les autres députés du nouveau
brunswick gilles lepage a vécu une
élection en pleine pandémie fini pour
lui le temps des bonnes vieilles
campagnes traditionnelles
vous savez comme un bon politique je
vous dirais même un policier acadiens
c'est encore plus difficile de prouver
capable de serrer les mains de regarder
les gens dans le visage
et d'abord des rassemblements ce qui lui
a fait prendre conscience d'une réalité
dignes du tiers monde dans sa propre
région
dans ma circonscription et j'ai
énormément de zones où est ce que les le
réseau internet n'est pas là où ils
prêts peu près mauvaise qualité
le député de restigouche s'est donc
donné une nouvelle mission améliorer
l'accès de ses électeurs à internet et
je pense qu'il faut absolument connecter
les citoyens les entrepreneurs nos
élèves mais nanti étudie à la maison
l'aider mais cinq sont rod qui ont paul
ohl le bon débit pour être capable de
faire des téléconférences et tellement
qu'on fait aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les coups de fil au bureau les courriels
les messages c'était sans arrêt sans des
petites entreprises qui voyait mais si
on ferme c'est des années d'efforts qui
vont s'écrouler n'était pas capable de
passer au travers
la députée néo-démocrate du nord de
l'ontario et porte parole de
l'opposition en matière de santé elle
doit siéger à queenstown impossible pour
elle de voyager par avion puisque le
transporteur régional a cessé ses
activités à cause de la qu'ovide passés
par l'aéroport pierce une smart phone
parce que tu dois faire confinement etc
elle doit donc faire cinq heures de
route pour se rendre à toronto
le télétravail n'étant pas implanté à la
législature
la goutte de salbris à toronto il ya 100
km que c'est un creux c'est une faute à
deux voies beaucoup beaucoup d'animaux
d'enfance d orgueil je veux et c'est
hélas cet hiver ça fait deux fois que je
que je descends la cuisse et c'est la
campagne tonnage que tu vois rien les
risques d'extension là je déteste ça
mais j'ai comme pas le choix
[Musique]
il
au mois d'octobre il fallait que je
vendais des du chocolat pur pour
l'argent pour mon école pour mon enfant
pour avoir d'aidé à des protections
personnel une vie familiale grandement
transformer aussi pour le chef du parti
libéral du manitoba dougall de la mode
trois de ses quatre enfants ont dû être
retirés de leur école à cause de la
qu'ovide les gens ils sont épuisés ils
sont 1
ils sont fatigués et surtout pour lui a
eu pour ceux qui vivent de pauvreté
parce qu'il ya presque les aider le
gouvernement conservateur manitoba a
adopté une approche financière très
prudente pendant la crise de sanitaires
les dépenses publiques pour stimuler
l'économie ont été minimales communes
une incendie et les grands consommateurs
sont en train de décider de ne pas
utiliser l'eau mais enfin à malgré
qu'ils y ont développé une sens
d'indépendance puis je dirais c'est une
des
des effets positifs de devenir député
parce qu'ils y ont dû apprendre à faire
plusieurs choses dans mon absence
la pandémie a forcé tout le monde y
compris les députés à revoir leurs
priorités tant du point de vue personnel
que professionnel
parfois pour le mieux